hello welcome back to youtube gaming
stage right here PAX Prime and Seattle
I'm your host Daniel Dwyer joined by mr.
Justin hey Walt hello Justin hey years
ago beautiful cap I love it very Pokemon
of you and oh my god game explain miss
Ivor's how are you doing sir doing great
thank you it's like kings for alumni as
I'm back I didn't realize your ex game
guy gender I've missed bigger man it's
good to be back thanks so much i'm
coming on and Justin you prepared
something for our dear and so we we
brought some super mario maker Andre and
I have both been playing a whole lot of
this game and one of the most exciting
things about Mario maker are getting to
play other people's creations right so
Andre as a Mario expert as someone who's
already put a lot of time into Super
Mario maker I went through and I
selected an assortment of courses so
again that I made some that are ok
difficult and some that are gonna be so
brutally difficult than I expect him to
be crying before the end of this demo ok
so here's hammer how many of you picked
so far how many we got well I want to
get through at least eight there's six
hour 12 total here ok but if you can get
through all 12 that's pretty optimistic
man this first one this first one
shouldn't be too bad all right let
something go to warm up give it your
best shot on joy so how many do you
think you you have you played any of
these ones before 90 of these no I ok
sorry start Robbie's a car you are yeah
dad in two seconds unbelievable so in
Super Mario maker you know you're able
to just set the graphics for the game on
the different types of Mario yeah here
the original classic Mario there's also
super mario brothers three super mario
world and Oh remember others you oh well
oh that's not it that's impossible I do
not have Oscar you know you have to hold
off the ride yeah well so I think
there's a distinction between people who
pulled brought all the time and people
who sometimes hold run I'm definitely a
always hold run kind of person oh no I
am too I think I started late the first
time so when they begin to this platform
in time oh yeah
this is a very doable stage this is a
warm-up oh and a moose boost should be
well ok this is very i'm using this is a
not setting the stage well for the end
stages to come after so it is a who's
playing mario maker at the moment cuz i
know the price half of some youtubers
have a good well what's the quality of
level creation been like so far but
considering like not all the public's
had a chance to like make some [ __ ]
yet I mean it's definitely more limited
than what we're gonna see once though
the full game comes out but there's
still like the hundreds of people
playing from all around the world oh
when you're picking stages you can see a
little flag next to you the person's
name so like all the Americans have the
American flag a bunch of Germans and
Italians people fall over the world are
creating level two now any Irish I
haven't seen a tireless [ __ ] on Irish
Mike Oh typically is it this is this
might be the run this is gonna be so
close how much is left after that part
what is right that's not good 11 says
like three quarters of the way like this
there's that innocence so i get like
gives you the star but white it's kirby
because you can run the time it's like
air ride oh yah he's gonna write another
classic and so a lot of people are doing
old washes the other day because you're
able to use amiibo and create or put
these characters it again but they don't
have any different powers they don't
react in any way differently like a sign
yes it's mario is currently wearing
Kirby's flesh yes he is still curvy and
his daughter we go that's in go to the
blood oh nice work madam a boss great
job one down 99 to go how long do we
have time you know all right so this
next one also shouldn't be too hard okay
which one tilt back out it would be on
tour so that's Kirby because somebody
owns a Kirby amiibo who made the level
right and then got it in there yes you
put your your amiibo on there you able
to set a mushroom that will turn you
into that that different carrier what's
the weirdest to me boy you've seen look
at this good jump I really been after I
went for it watch your head down this
yes this would
easy just have to get the spin jump down
so in Super Mario World your little spin
jump across a lot of obstacles that
would normally kill you okay Wow like
right there honey you know you're in
jail the level crater just did that just
a mess with your patrol right now so
it's a little bit of caution yeah I mean
you see what kind of a player you are as
well when you're seeing these these
creations and what kind of level creator
so I like as someone for me personally I
don't like creating levels in most games
even littlebigplanet like I just don't
do a very good job and I love playing
other people's levels Mario maker if you
like a little bit different I feel like
I actually able to to make levels that
are fun that you won't hear you can't
slide under you can do it did you smell
oh that just makes it hot can you slide
can you guys get in there again Slyder
dumbbell go stop so and the other thing
to point out I haven't made all these
levels but I have beaten all of them
okay yeah but you probably beat them on
your like 50th attempt I'm not gonna say
how many a time I played an error of
this with him last week on gamespot com
and there was a lot of oh yeah I just
don't quite eating dirt all right here
we go and so this is a mode where we're
just kind of free playing levels like I
went through I chose these levels
beforehand so worried is good at that
spike it did it again come on but there
are also challenges that kind of give
you a set of random levels he's not
spinning this is gonna be bad oh jeez
what's over yeah you have to be spinning
it all right that sucks is that that's
the most hair-raising part of doing this
is that you never you're like is it over
yet is it over and there's like no all
this never over now this one's not too
long either
I think I think it took me like two or
three times to get through them all and
it did it did it Justin yeah only two or
three right yeah he was doing it at home
and his underwear had one in the morning
Rio buddy watching a hold nobody was
watching but yeah there's a little more
pressure here come on the crowd there
staring either they want you to win
giggles want to visit a sports do this
oh oh oh get those coins redundant nice
oh my goodness you know my girl yet now
because he's seeing Bell oh yes my heart
is racing right now all right beautiful
text all right we've got like I think
we're like halfway through it so you can
feel free to push it up a little bit no
no no now from for push it up you cannot
see me in that that was not that was
that was still the warmup oh the warm-up
are these are the levels that I've made
oh great all right so you're seeing a
broken right so this next one's called
jumper the trick to this one is jumping
oh really so you think it's a mario game
all right leap of faith okay so far so
good that's wrong yeah this is great
it's like my counter strike days jump
ma'am there's gonna be some precision
jump so this is
now if you kill them or do you use them
ah you do neither so it's a little bit
of a [ __ ] with a fire flower just to
see if some people are just like really
trigger-happy they start killing thanks
that's the that's missing you don't want
to do that right and I had to move to
the right nice Mirfak just like your
first run so is there a lot of them like
level design trolling happening oh
they're like like they make you big and
then you can't get under something like
ever well show it whenever you upload a
level like the person who created has to
be able to feed it you can't write in a
level that's literally impossible
someone had to have gotten through it
however there's a there's a lot of
things that you can put in here that are
more attentive ah so super mario
brothers too but in America we got a
game called super mario brothers student
was actually doki doki panick ok Japan
the actual super mario brothers who
looked a lot like this morning or if
they're like league originally except
that it was on super hardcore mode it
was really really difficult it had lots
of hidden blocks like as you would go to
make a jump across something you would
hit a hidden block in it would fit you
into the pit or there are gusts of wind
that would knock you off of platforms
and this is kind of more akin to that
being able to make levels that are just
complete jerks so this is the this is
the American audience finally getting
there Mario too well we did get a Mario
too late yeah me oh gee you ever played
great giana sisters I took not Whelan
that's what the Commodore kids played we
didn't have Mario there's no way I was
an intern to again oh my goodness how
much is left on this one this is right
near the end he's gonna they're almost
there come on you can do it come on
being big makes that that final joke a
little bit easier Kenny's got it no pass
round of a book nice work I do you did
that faster you did number two yeah
wasn't that bad i don't-- wasn't warm up
i think i'm gonna groove now so greasing
them up this next one is called what
goes up must come down okay I don't mind
so you're gonna be able to see what
you're getting into before you get into
the level but I think another
interesting thing about this version of
mario is they're able to add sound
effects you're able to add things like a
beating heart so like right now you can
see that oh yeah i mean that's actually
a live feed from a heartbeat right now
and so you're looking to the right and
like i imagine that as you're going up
your artist being a little faster you
can put in moments like that where
Bowser's head comes in oh can you
seriously do that if you have to
complete it right yeah I had to make it
through so this is this is possible you
couldn't put a checkpoint at the top the
one thing that you're not able to do in
Super Mario maker is is at checkpoints
ok but and I wanted to make sure like
you see what you're getting into you get
that heart beating you can use that
doors though to sort of make separate
areas right yeah if you wanted to you
get I could have put a door the bottom
warm up to the top but then you miss out
on all this fun
come on oh all right try Thanks work
that's a poem boy it's a good one that
was when you made yeah is when I imagine
it took me once I had to play through it
to beat it that took me a lot more than
that how long did it take you to make
the level you can make levels pretty
quickly like I I think that one maybe
took me 30 minutes or 20 minutes you're
able to paint levels to make things in a
really interesting way and one thing
you're also able to do is to make levels
like this winners don't do shrooms
that's true games they in the kind of
play with that Mario is done that's not
obvious but worst part I played this
level before I knew he was there so in
Mario games you you know you're always
running from the beginning to the end
and you expect power-ups to be helpful
but in this in this game that this
person is made mushrooms are actually
going to make it impossible for you to
progress forward if you collect a
mushroom he's gonna run he's gonna make
it through a point later in Halawa or he
can not go forward he has to avoid all
of the mushrooms here is a stopping so
he has to be one has to be small to get
through that was a good slide but
demonstrate game oh my god so the reason
there's a piranha plant right there is
for you to reset so once you get big if
you're like oh I I accidentally hit a
mushroom you go back to the Piranha play
on it figure self small so it's not
actually an obstacle as much as it it is
a reset point or kind of a safe ride so
you gotta go to whole way without hit in
the mushroom oh my god oh my god oh
might as well just eat them all up yeah
well so the other trick to this is that
some of the mushrooms will disappear
some well so it's like the auto maybe
just collect a bunch of them or try to
get the timing so that you can get
through some of the jump saying get rid
of the mushrooms that are all like
random like this one you can make that
jump oh but they're also gonna start
coming out of these pipes she's the
flying one so are the real pain you can
do it
oh how long is this level so this is the
halfway point once you get on it once he
gets to that checkpoint then he has to
do another set of it oh they get Doc's
not go down there doc jerk Oh almost oh
i think i think i'll make it to the
halfway point night all right we believe
in you and once you get to halfway point
there's another piranha plant where if
you hit another mushroom you're able to
reset you don't have to go all the way
back to the beginning anyway oh my gosh
nice work halfway so good job that was
also the warm-up part of this stage now
it's a little bit hard okay oh my gross
there's one point where he's he's
definitely going to have to go back
you'll you'll see where that is coming
oh I would I recommend just still going
for it there's another point coming up
where you need to oh I could've kept
going from that even bigger you should
keep going ok all right ok it happen I
think I just know I get through no no oh
my god oh my god well this next part is
where there's no way for you to get past
this you have to just knock up all of
these and then go collect him in the top
oh no don't Oh ridiculous and so then
once he goes up he collects those
mushrooms that he just put he can go
back get hit by the Piranha plant and
then he should be able to make it
through the rest to say like most of
them are fine with the time but this one
actually seems like it's difficult like
you've only got 396 second oh yeah you
can totally run out of time flexees now
let's go ahead and go back oh go get
small and now you can make it through
good idea give her the mushrooms yeah no
need to make it harder on yourself
without it this is hell so unfortunately
because these are on a test server like
right now this is mostly for reviewers
and for people to try out the game early
right none of these stages are gonna
exist in the actual game they're gonna
reset the whole show them all of these
levels that we've made we will have to
remake oh jeez oh wow you made it
usually I waiting at the bottom
stress more stressful i thought pax
would be
come on oh wow he's born to jumping look
at that oh yeah I taught you all I say
darlin so this isn't the end it's not
over it's not over God Almighty still a
little bit ago what Oh No is there a
plant down here no no no this that was
not the reset point don't hit me don't
hit that ah oh my god can you keep going
he can recent like we're here you can go
back to the beginning but that's the end
oh I know popping late but I think it's
interesting that people are lucky but
now just kind of thinking about ways
that they can make changes that play
with your expectations and what a mario
game itself is oh oh you gotta got a
whole the way back yeah oh you have to
go back to the midway point I wish there
was another checkpoint and I don't other
thing once you can download these levels
and then you can kind of play with them
yourself and remake them and change them
so if you're like I do that a little bit
better you can actually do that you can
download the level in and remake it
yourself if you want you we'd certainly
an idea yeah I think I think we're not a
we run at a time on my sofa I had to end
on max is good yes well you can we're
gonna play try 40 seconds so we will
maybe you separate them so yeah and
we're cooperating on that when you're
trying to torture me though a good level
selected and a random applause like
really just great work especially on
that one one that took him like 30 times
yeah all right we'll be back stay tuned
if you're watching us our course on
YouTube gaming right now if you're on
the game spot at page make sure you hit
that add button and we'd be back in a
second you sell the fans who want to
stick around so stay there
you